freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
neuen video ich bin heute in berlin ich
habe nämlich das video am sonntag mit
kevin hier gedreht also ein tag
persönlich jakob und ihr seht bereits im
hintergrund cottbus hat vor
warum die artikel gelesen wir testen
heute ein paar von shirin david fuß
ports glaubt mit eines der
meistgeklickten videos im
deutschsprachigen raum 6 millionen
aufrufe waren dort aus dem video gemacht
das wusste ich noch nicht habe ich aber
gerade gesehen deshalb verliere ich euch
das auch mal und wir testen als erstes
diese mir kräfte dass es hier am
kottbusser tor muss ich wörter auch ich
bin sehr gespannt das ist doch
eigentlich hab ich darf auf die
zubereitung film deshalb wird sehr wild
und gucke mir das mal an die natürlich
genau die gleiche bestellung ist er
ihnen auch genommen hat damit ist das
bestmöglich vergleichen kann
[Musik]
okay die waren so netten habe ich auch
filmen lassen deshalb konnte ich ein
bisschen ball einblenden ich bin sehr
gespannt also wir haben hier den weg auf
uns genommen und verdienen hat in
höchsten tönen davon gesprochen deshalb
kommen wir sonst mal an ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich hab ich selten in meinem leben
kräfte gegessen also ich habe nur mal so
die pflegekräfte gegessen und so sieht
das ganze aus china habe ich gesagt das
droht muss nicht knusprig sein sondern
muss es hören können ich glaube hat
funktioniert mein erster bis der erste
fußball ich weiß wir frühstücken das
gerade also wundert euch nicht
red
wenn sie diese kleinen kräfte die frisch
angebraten abendrot ist superbrands für
mich auch etwas neues also neu
entdeckten gesagt hätten ich bewerte am
ende leute ihren mund halten und ich bin
jetzt gerade halb durch
dieses brot
diese schärfe
ich schwör's es wirklich unnormal lecker
ich glaube der krieg straighten mit zehn
von zehn von mir no go also noch mal ran
hinterher ich hoffe hilft ein bisschen
gegen diese despoten die hey leute
das war krass das ermöglicht hat das war
höchster beste kräfte den gästen wie
gesagt selten passiert aber einfach
heftig lecker wie zähneputzen sind set
und ich hoffe dass wir ihn weiterhin
guten geschmack beweist ab zur nächsten
mahlzeit freunde zeit für den zweiten
fuß bord ich bin sehr aufgeregt denn es
geht heute um etwas was ich persönlich
nicht auf die leichte schulter nehmen
es geht um den shirin david behauptet
der laden zu dem wir jetzt fahren ist
der beste dünger in berlin und ja
vielleicht mein video gesehen mit rief
da habe ich gesagt in berlin gibt es den
besten döner überhaupt also ist das für
mich quasi der beste dünger auch der
welt angeblich den wir jetzt testen
werden super an heißt der laden und ich
hoffe dass ich vielleicht auch wieder
ein bisschen was für euch filmen kann
wir sind jetzt gleich da ich hab hunger
danach muss natürlich noch weiter
gegessen werden aber den können wir uns
jetzt erst mal let's go und da guckt man
hier auf dem navi 50 meter es ist
wirklich sehr unscheinbar also es ist
genau so wie das heute morgen so nichts
davon irgendwie färbt das sondern heute
morgen natürlich das essen überzeugt
aber super an hier auf der rechten ist
und keine schlacken
[Musik]
freunde der döner ist komplett voll
gepackt bin sehr gespannt was ein paar
pommes drin beratende tätigkeit mache
und es ist mein erster gemüse wird
versuchen
vielleicht doch für das erlebnis bin
sehr gespannt war ich vom 8
ist ja dann danach als döner die den ich
kenne
ich gebe meine endgültige bewertung und
ehrlich sehr krass fiel die ernte gerade
eben schon dass der döner einfach
irgendwie so leicht schmeckt das klingt
total bescheuert weil ich meine dass
frittiertes gemüse sein aber irgendwie
ist das echt so ein kind natürlich ist
es nicht gesund aber also freunde
abschließende bewertungen das war für
mich wirklich auf jeden fall top3 dünner
und ich würde dem döner auch eine starke
neun von zehn geben auf jeden fall
es hat nicht aber nicht ganz so sehr
abgeholt wie die köpfe heute morgen die
waren schon nochmal next level ich muss
natürlich an dieser stelle auch mal
loswerden shirin du hast sehr gute
fußballs ausgewählt das macht mir sehr
viel spaß mich durch zu testen aber ich
kann auch ganz gut kochen also ich habe
eine firma hat einen tag per sind jakob
könne da mal dabei sein willst mich
nicht freunde ansonsten ich sage euch
ganz ehrlich leute ich habe heute nichts
anderes gegessen ich weiß nicht wie sie
sieben spots an einem tag machen konnte
ich habe bauchschmerzen ich werde jetzt
noch den burger snacken und dann falle
ich ins koma da gehe ich aber darauf
freue ich mich jetzt noch mal wir sehen
uns dort
oder sind wir auch kommen das erste mal
dass durch diesen schlange ist also erst
mal geht preislich tod ist klar
doppelte cheeseburger 580 ich glaube der
war auch riesengroß ich habe auf meinem
pc bekommen also wenn das vielleicht
fertig ist weiß bescheid
wir durften leider nicht bei der
zubereitung filmen aber ihr seht er
selbst jetzt ziemlich viel los und ich
glaube wenn an einer drin ist und so
wäre es schwierig deshalb nehme ich das
einfach zum mitnehmen und wir es nicht
machen vielleicht auch ganz gemütlich im
auto und dann klingt auch diese wirklich
sehr leckere tagaus so freunde hier ist
die bag wir haben eine großzügige
tragetasche voll mit burger und pommes
und ich habe tatsächlich dass er ihn in
ihrem video gesagt jemanden gehört der
hat gesagt dass die süßkartoffel pommes
anders sind sind sehr gespannt war
das habe ich für das rasche ich mag auch
süßkartoffel kommen ist ja gar nicht ab
hier ist erst mal der bürger drin so
leute jetzt mal ehrlich ganz kurz fünf
euro 80 ist anders für diesen bürger da
sieht man direkt das ist nämlich anders
fährt dieser bürger ist sehr sehr rich
sieht fast aus als seine / paris und das
ist ja bekannterweise mich sehr lecker
aber ich starte glaube ich mit dem
süßkartoffel pommes weil die sollen ja
soll dieses next level sein meine ich
natürlich fünf minuten hier schon drin
also so sehen die süßkartoffel pommes
aus die test macht
man kann es erst wirklich sagen wenn man
sie mit mario gegessen hat findet die
süßkartoffel kommen springen nur mit
mario vázquez kompletter ways mayo schon
sehr sehr gut
ich muss sagen leute ich war kritisch
oder ich bin kritisch
dem bürger gegenüber bezeichnet ihn
dadurch als den besten burger wie ihr
wisst ich habe viele bürger übrig und
ich würde damit nicht leichtfertig um
nicht werfen deshalb nicht sehr sehr
gespannt wie sich dieser bürger hier
schlägt wir sehen schon american jazz
sehr gute entscheidung sehr wichtig wir
sehen eine bürgerpflicht dieses match
sein können probiere jetzt also erstmal
für das was man hier machst du bekommst
und so ist der preis superfähren ich
würde direkt sagen das ist nicht der
beste burger gegessen habe
das ist ein sehr solider bürger aber
dafür wieder aufgebaut ist so dieses
weiche software bahn american kiesbett
hat er zu wenig dieses das ist nur nach
einem schmeckt also man schmecken also
die verschiedenen bestandteile raus was
in diesem fall für mich zumindest
negatives habe es trotzdem sehr sehr
lecker was wie gesagt super
und ich falsch verstehen also es
wirklich ein sehr stabiler bürger aber
in diesem kontext heute würde ich den
anderen beiden restaurants unrecht tun
wenn er nicht eine acht von zehn
bekommen würde
nichtsdestotrotz danke als shirin dass
sie diese kleinen restaurants geheiratet
hat so dass ich sie heute testen durfte
wir sehen uns spätestens sonntag wieder
wenn es heißt ein tag persönlicher koch
macht es gut bis dahin tschüss